Sansa Stark the lady of Winterfell thank
you for inviting us into your home lady
Stark
Winterfell is yours your grace hi
everyone is Charlie this is gonna be my
Game of Thrones season 8 episode 1 video
congratulations you all made it now
everybody grab your Valyrian swords and
hop a dragon let's go I'll be doing
videos all season long if you're brand
new to the channel be sure to subscribe
to get all the videos I also do a weekly
HBO now giveaway all you have to do to
enter that is be a subscriber and leave
a comment on the video there was so much
stuff in the episode to cover so many
Easter eggs and references to earlier
episodes particularly the pilot episode
that I did this like a top 15 instead of
my normal top 10 careful for spoilers if
you have not seen the episode yet so
starting with number 15 the brand new
intro sequence they got a major upgrade
to not only the map table that it pans
around but also the astrolabe itself you
notice that the emblems aren't only just
the house sigils they also tell the
story of A Song of Ice and Fire
they even referenced the Dragons in the
comet from way back in season 1 if you
ever wondered whether or not they would
reference the comet again you also
probably picked up on the fact that the
intro sequence begins from the knight
Kings perspective because you start
facing south you crush through the wall
is the camera pans around you notice the
deep blue tiles flipping over on the
regular winter tiles just denoting their
paths as they come straight down to the
last hearth so the map table itself is
telling you where the night king is
going it's basically telling you the
story of the show episode by episode
like they came down to the last part
first then they're turning to Winterfell
the other important thing too is that
when they take you through each of the
bigger locations like Winterfell and
King's Landing you actually go inside
the buildings they particularly denote
places like the crypts because that's
where Jon Snow finds the truth about his
parents when you're in King's Landing
they also remind you about the scorpion
that's pointing at balerion the black
dread skull underneath the throne room
just because there's gonna be a big
threat to Daenerys his dragons this
season because Cersei is still on the
opposite side of this I don't know how
effective it'd be against vissarion's
since technically he's still dead I
suppose you could do enough damage to
his wings with enough scorpion bolts
that you could probably bring him down
that way 14 Jon Snow and Daenerys
arrived at Winterfell so if you couldn't
tell this is a giant homage to the pilot
episode when Robert Baratheon arrived
they even had the same soundtrack when
they were marching in the name of the
song is the King arrives so they also do
a mirror scene you know if you remember
the pilot
so you see Aria running through the
crowd she jumps up on top of that wagon
to get a good vantage point but this
time it's another northerner a little
boy whose perspective you're getting is
he sort of runs through the crowd he
rushes past Aria who smiles at him
because she's taller now they make a
joke about her being taller later in the
episode so she can see just fine he
climbs on top of a branch just like bran
climbed on top of the castle to get a
better look it's a progression of Aria
smiles as people went by she got really
excited when Jon Snow went by like she
wanted to call out to him but she wasn't
quite sure so she let him pass but then
she saw the Hound in Gendry smiled even
bigger she gave the biggest reaction
when the dragons flew overhead though
just that look of wonder blooming on her
face that was the one that they put in
the teaser that we kept seeing earlier
this year the look on Santa's face when
the dragons fly overhead looks more like
worry but we all know about the Sansa
Daenerys drama that's gonna be happening
the first couple of episodes so it just
sort of laying the seeds for that like
she's worried about Daenerys and what's
going to happen with her being up there
thirteen Jon Snow introduces Daenerys to
the stark family in the northern Lords
so there's a couple awkward moments a
couple funny moments just like Robert
Baratheon greeting all the Starks so
John just rushes to hug bran because
they haven't seen each other since
season one Sansa is happy to see him
again but then it gets really awkward
once Daenerys walks out that was the
shot in the trailer that we kept seeing
your grace Winterfell is yours and
here's all the shade in the world but if
you look in the background of these
shots even funnier is the little bear
who's staring daggers next to yon Royce
I feel like the way they played the
brand reveal telling Daenerys about
Viserion being an undead white at the
command of the night King was played as
a little bit of a dark joke to just cut
the tension we don't have time for this
I need to tell you about all the
terrible things that happened to your
child and they do it again later in the
episode when Daenerys is talking to Sam
well a lot of really dark but funny
moments at the same time you feel kind
of bad for laughing at them particularly
when Samwell is finding out about his
family dying but things only continue to
get more awkward towards the end of the
episode they just want to set up the
drama plot for the next couple of
episodes so number twelve Jon Snow
versus the little bear and the rest of
the northern Lords they don't waste any
time and digging into him so this is all
about setting up the idea that they
started last season where the northern
Lords got really pissed at Jon for
leaving and now they're even more upset
because he bent the knee and he's no
longer technically king in the north
there was even the funny joke about
little Lord umber not being sure what
the power structure was because
has so many people at the front of the
table he said milady to Santa then
milord to Jon Snow then your grace to
Daenerys that was obviously just to
remind you that he was a character on
the show so that the reveal at the end
of the episode when the night King used
him for finger paints was that much more
shocking 11 was the Tyrion and Sansa
reunion
I felt so bad about Tyrion in this
episode they are really laying it on
thick I used to think that you were the
cleverest man alive this is sort of like
the beginning of the end for Tyrion say
your prayers
if you thought that he made bad
decisions during season seven all the
times in the episode that he assured
everyone including the northern Lords in
front of everyone that Cersei was
definitely going to be sending them
reinforcements is not gonna bode well
when Jaime arrives and tries to explain
to them what's really going on they have
a couple more of those really dark funny
moments joking about Joffrey's wedding
oh it had its moments like Sansa was
really happy that he died but you kind
of bolted well we both survived
congratulations I think a lot of this
isn't so much about making Sansa seem
smarter I think it's more about making
Tyrion seem like he's slowly falling
from grace just like making one bad call
after another that really ominous look
that brand gives him at the end of the
episode does not bode well for Tyrion so
just say your prayers but number 10 Jon
Snow re reunion in the godswood you used
to be taller like making another joke
about re being super tall and not
needing to climb up on that wagon like
she did during the pilot they make a
couple references to her being a
faceless person how did you sneak up on
me how did you survive a knife to the
heart probably one of the funniest Jon
Snow jokes that he's ever told
I didn't survive so never let it be said
that Jon Snow could never tell a joke as
his his sense of humor is very Ned Stark
they have a nice embrace referencing a
moment from season 1 episode 2 when he
gave her a needle you used it a couple
times another joke yeah used it a couple
then several times after that us
remembering all the people that she's
killed the weird thing about the long
Claud moment though is that I don't know
what kind of payoff they were trying to
give because she has the dagger she
didn't tell him about it are you jealous
that I have this giant Valyrian sword it
seems a little weird that she wouldn't
have wit the dagger out and shown him in
that moment all the talk about Arya
taking Sansa side in all these arguments
is just paying off that art from last
season
the lone wolf dies but the pack survives
that was what that Littlefinger plot was
all about so one that lets you know that
there's not going to be any kind of
drama between Arya and Sansa this season
but it all
leads into that quote where John says
just remind her that I'm her family too
and Aria says don't you forget that
either because he's getting ready to
find out whose parents truly are so he's
gonna be conflicted about his family but
the stark family will still treat him
like family ari is just trying to remind
him of that so this is all set up for
that big payoff at the end of the
episode number nine the golden company
arrives at King's Landing this is also
one of those really dark and funny
moments because Cersei he's got this
weird smile on her face like she's very
smug Qyburn runs out to tell her your
grace it's terrible the dead have
breached the wall and all she can say is
good that's great and walks back in to
receive the golden company they lay a
little bit of groundwork in their
conversation for a year on versus
everyone else type of conflict where you
find out that he probably killed a
couple members of the golden company
says oh you know they weren't good
warriors you won't miss them they were
cheating at games or maybe I was
cheating I don't remember so it
definitely sounds like he killed him and
Harry Strickland is it really happy
about it but he's putting up with it
because Cersei is paying them so much
money so obviously I've already done a
couple videos about the golden company
their background I'm hoping for a couple
really big moments from them this season
a couple big battles but I don't know
how big they're gonna be and how much of
their history they're gonna get into if
they're any big Easter eggs and videos
or scenes then I'll let you guys know
but for now they're just sort of laying
a little bit of groundwork although they
do have a joke about elephants and I
wonder if that was because the
production the producers didn't want to
deal with the hassle of filming with
elephants so she had a couple lines of
dialogue that felt like they were very
meta jokes from the writers just talking
to the fans like we really really wanted
to see some elephants but we couldn't
afford it and it's too difficult to deal
with when you're trying to film a big
battle scene so I don't know whether or
not we're actually gonna see elephants
this season or if they'll pay that off
later but number eight then you have the
Cersei vs. Euron subplot with him trying
to bed her to make good on their
agreement worse take a long time why
don't we just get this over with right
now and there's this weird look on her
face like you wonder what her thought
process is like is she just trying to
keep him under her thumb is she worried
that he's going to propel against her
because she definitely hates him do you
want to keep your head attached to your
body and then after he leaves it almost
seems like she's gonna throw up in her
wine glass she definitely hates Iran and
is trying to outmaneuver him but number
seven welcome back bran who is now
officially teamed Cersei although he
does look conflicted about it he really
wants that castle I think that's the
justification for
character standpoint love it or hate it
I do love that funny conversation that
he has with the girls in his bed I'm one
of the only people that's ever brought
down a dragon that's a big deal like
he's trying to remind them about how
he's an important person the comedic
timing of this scene with Qyburn is
almost perfect though I think that was
more to pay off the WTF moment at the
end when he found out exactly what
Cersei wanted him to do but is the young
woman propositions Qyburn you know I'm
very fond of old men and he says oh poor
girl she's gonna die of pox within the
year and bronto most chokes on his wine
which girl are you talking about
then Qyburn explains that should Jaime
and Tyrion survive the war with the dead
Cersei wants Bronn to kill them in
poetic justice wants him to do it using
the crossbow the Tyrion used to kill
Tywin during season 4 this is the same
crossbow that he used against him so I
think this is just the beginning of a
bunch of main characters making really
good or really terrible choices and
they're not leading to their eventual
demise
so if you notice characters making
morally reprehensible decisions during
episodes it probably means they're
headed for some big come up and so
something terrible might wind up
happening to Bronn 6 Fionna and his
Ironborn rescue Yara off a Hurons boat I
love the way that she just head-butted
him that was for being so weak and not
being able to rescue her and stand up to
your on back during season 7 remember he
just stood there and pissed himself when
you're on challenge him come over here
take her from me now he seems a little
more sure of himself then he splits with
her to go back to Winterfell to fight
the army of the Dead and be more
honorable she goes back to the Iron
Islands to try and take them because
they aren't being defended by Euron at
the moment maybe Theon will make it
there before the big episode 3 battle
but number 5 Jon Snow finally rides
ragle for the first time he rides a
dragon one of the biggest questions that
fans have had ever since we learned that
he was a secret Targaryen even before
that when people suspected it but it
hadn't been proven yet the funny thing
about this too is that Ragle even
cuddles up to him like a puppy before
they begin and they kind of play it for
comedy with him flying all over the
dragon but he seems like a natural in
the place where they land is a huge call
back to Ygritte and Jon Snow's cave they
even give Daenerys a couple lines of
dialogue very similar to what Ygritte
said to John Snow while they were still
in the cave don't go let's stay in this
cave forever dinner says we could stay
in here for a thousand years and even
funnier - was dragons
to their public display of affection but
he's just being protective but Johnson
oh just that look of terror on his face
as drogon gets really protective of her
for was Gendry aria and the hounds
reunion now obviously she has very
different types of relationships with
both of those people like the Hound was
being a little more grew up with her you
seem like a cold [ __ ] but I suppose
that's why you're still alive that's his
way of telling her that he's happy to
see her I'm happy that you're still
alive
the Gendry reunion also had a couple
lines of dialogue referencing moments
that they had together back during
season 3 where she said you could be my
family and he says no you would be my
ladies so he calls her my lady couple
times she finally smiles but they also
lay the seeds for the special weapon
quote-unquote that he's going to be
creating for her using her Valyrian
dagger so it's just a really large
spirit you saw during the trailer when
she's spinning it around in that huge
battle so it's just gonna be a really
cool badass weapon and he gave the
hounds the big upgrade of the dragon
glass axe 3 was Daenerys his
conversation with Samwell that went off
the rails so quickly in the most
wonderful way possible the whole reason
she sought him out was to thank him for
curing Serge auras greyscale during
season 7 she makes it sound like she's
going to reinstate him as a student in
the citadel or even name him as a
full-blown maester just something really
wonderful he's really excited and they
start talking about Valyrian swords and
that's how they get to her burning his
family their timing during this was
perfect but you kind of feel bad for
chuckling a little bit so he says well
my father's dead that's awful but at
least my brothers still alive
I'll get to go home and she's like no
can't do that I burned your brother too
that's when he loses it but look at the
nurse's reaction she is stone cold as if
she'd do it again in a heartbeat if she
had to the look on Sir George face in
the background while this is happening
is priceless - but this sort of leads
Samwell to talk to bran in the r + l
equals j so number - Samwell finally
tells John the truth about R + L equals
J you were never a bastard so John is at
Ned Stark statue trying to make sense of
everything and Sam confronts him about
the death of his family and they try to
play it as if they're questioning
Daenerys his honor also - when he tells
him the truth about being the true heir
to the Iron Throne
Daenerys didn't tell you the truth about
what she did to my family isn't that
interesting would Daenerys also set
aside her claim to the throne the way
that you set aside your crown to bend
the knee and save your people by forming
this alliance in the first place it's
all just drama that they're building
towards in episode 2 in the eventual at
three big battle the rest of the episode
is really just a parade of horror like
reactions that different characters have
to different situations Jaime arriving
at Winterfell satisfied with himself I'm
doing the honorable thing but then
immediately noticing brand in
recognizing him the look of horror and
remorse on his face is priceless but
number one we have to talk about that
genuine horror moment with the Nights
Watch at the last heart to the end of
the episode turns out they didn't get
those extra wagons and horses quite as
quickly as they needed so torment and
barrack have made it down from the wall
with a couple of the wildlings they run
into EDD in the Nights Watch who are
also investigating the last hearts and
they find little Lord umber who's been
turned into finger paints by the night
king who does not go quickly like they
try to set him on fire and he just
continues screaming and screaming they
just draw the scene right out it's a
really genuine classic horror moment
from Game of Thrones we don't get those
very often but because this is the final
season I'm expecting a little bit more
of this I did like the joke about
torment always having blue eyes just
another one of those weird comedic
moments they worked into the episode but
let me know in the comments what was
your favorite moment or your biggest WTF
what will happen is is I will do a
trailer video for episode two tomorrow
and I'll name a giveaway winner during
that I'm also doing Q&A videos that'll
probably be on Tuesday so leave all the
questions in the comments that you want
me to include in that or any just big
things that you were confused about
during the episode while you wait for
everything click here for all my Game of
Thrones season 8 trailer and promo
videos and click here to learn a little
bit more about what's going on with the
night came this season thank you so much
for watching everybody stay awesome I'll
see you guys tonight